- one boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we were gonna be talking
about Elon Musk on Joe Rogan experience
it was a super enriching conversation
that they had it is definitely one of my
favorite conversations that I've heard
between two people and I think it's
really important that we acknowledge
that this marks a really crucial pillar
and point in history where we can see
two intellectuals have discourse that's
multidisciplinary nuanced driven and
equanimous calm and fun and talking
about the future of humanity inspiring
people so huge thumbs up to that
conversation and we're gonna have a good
breakdown right now of kind of what was
discussed and those highlights and see
how we can potentially aim to make
things even more better so alright the
first thing that I want to showcase is
this post that I posted immediately
after the conversation because I think
that if we are really smart and
listening to what was being discussed we
would see that Elon referenced the
importance of AI and referenced the
importance Joe as well the joke saw it
and kept talking to him about it
Elon made it very clear he's been trying
to have this conversation with so many
people on the planet that are leaders
across government entrepreneurs
different places in the world and people
are just not listening to him and this
is the problem right here and we'll show
it to you right now and the post that I
made I said that can you believe that
Elon looks at AI and talks warns about
AI ethics and then all of the media
outlets talk about his smoking weed on
the show
smoking marijuana has so little to do
with the important of part of the
conversation the important part of
conversations and weigh heavily weighted
in artificial intelligence and our
future with AI future with
at the ethics around that and so little
in marijuana and weed but yet all the
news outlets were about that so shows
you how stupid our mainstream media is
it shows you how clickbait t our
mainstream media is and our culture is
in that sense it shows you how
distracted our culture is away from what
is actually important so let's focus on
what's important which is artificial
intelligence the ethics around that the
morals around that geopolitics around AI
and how it's gonna be built so alright
moving on what we're gonna go break down
this episode so kind of one of the first
main things that I thought was important
that I wish Joe pushed Ilan back a
little bit on was the boring company so
Ellen's making it very clear that this
idea of digging tunnels under Los
Angeles and under all these heavily
trafficked areas and going past this
two-dimensional surface you see
three-dimensional buildings next to
two-dimensional roadways right it
doesn't make any sense so if you have
all those people up and you have all
those people that could only go in one
dimension on 2d you're inevitably gonna
have traffic so Elon is building 3d he's
going underground with the tunnels but
there are many companies like Kitty Hawk
that are working on vertical takeoff and
landing cars so flying cars actually
have the same third dimensional
potential they can go up in the air and
fly and land so it's really difficult to
know how long it's gonna take for cars
to be able to fly over long distances
like we see with Kitty Hawk and other
companies that are working on this
versus if it's actually worth the
resources and infrastructure and
investment that we're putting in to
building tunnels underground and Ilan's
right in many ways that this magnetic
Lev maglev in a vacuum tunnel
underground is extremely fast it's not
ma it's not module you can't you can't
turn the tunnel and you know pivot in in
a direction I don't know if you maybe
put some sort of a mechanism on on the
on the sides that could pivot it in the
direction then you'd have to dig out
that entire direction on
ground so that it could go like that but
you get the ideas that vertical takeoff
and landing can go anywhere but this
sort of limitation and amount of
infrastructure that we're gonna build
out with the boring might not actually
be what we'll use in a decade if we can
really get good at vertical takeoff and
landing so it's just food for thought I
wish there was some pushback I would
have loved to hear that I still don't
know how I feel about musk selling
flamethrowers that's oh that's kind of a
crazy thought process it's it's it's a
little bit you know fun but dangerous so
not really quite sure how to feel about
that and it's it's kind of weird that he
said don't buy the flamethrower but he
still made it so it's just it's just a
very strange thing to unpack ok so this
is another thing that I would have
really liked to hear more about so this
idea about time management and about how
musk is at Tesla and he's at SpaceX and
then he's at doing a lot of other work
with open AI and his other projects and
if it's even possible to manage
someone's family five kids and also the
two the two billion dollar companies he
has and all these other and works that
he's working on Annie's an investor in
many companies so how he's managing to
do that I wish we could unpack that more
and also I would like to unpack not only
his balance with his work in life but
also I'd like to unpack how it feels to
be a human that is at that level because
there are a lot of people that are
trying to ask you for things and I just
wonder how it feels to be a human that
constantly has to watch your back
because people can be potentially trying
to in some way take advantage of you and
what's going on and and you know it's
it's a difficult process to figure out
who is trustworthy and who need you need
to push away from a bit
that's a tough process and it would have
been nice to unpack that a bit Joe
Rogan's even get some of that Joe Rogan
doesn't being like Astrid
either so I wonder how within the power
distribution of the hierarchy when
people get higher up I want to know how
they engage with people in that sense
and how they build trust so I think that
would have been a really interesting
aspect to push back on a bit I thought
this was quite interesting there was a
lot of explain like I'm 5 going on Elon
Musk did a pretty good job at keeping
things non-technical and even when he
did make them technically try to make
them as relatable as possible and so I
think that his aspect of like of science
communication was just spot-on and
really good and then also just the
eccentricity in general I think is
something else that's really interesting
because if you if you think about how
eccentric musk is he kind of he doesn't
really worry about the way that he
speaks or the way that he's his arms
move or the way that his eyes move and
you can see this multiple times in the
video his eyes kind of you know go back
and forth looking downward or that he
will look he'll finish a sentence and
look at Joe and then he'll go and he'll
do that again it's like he liked not his
head and move forward towards Joe so the
idea is that these are kind of more
eccentric idiosyncrasies and behavior
and yet he is continuously totally
himself and doesn't mind that I think
that's really important to showcase the
kids and understand that hey no matter
where you are in social and behavior
like know that it's just fine to be you
and then at some point we will figure
out how to you know if someone is a
little bit way too eccentric and very
difficult for situation situations there
will be like some sort of an integration
but it's totally cool to walk on your
own path and all this other kind of
stuff so without going into that into
much detail I want to move on to this is
really important because we were talking
about AI at the beginning we're talking
about the percentage of intelligence
this is really important that is not
human is increasing and soon will be
smaller than the percentage of
intelligence that's not humans
increasing and soon it will serve
past the percentage of intelligence that
is human so oh right now arguably you
could say that there are there is more
intelligence on earth that is not human
because of animal intelligence there's
more animals intelligence than there is
human intelligence secondly is there is
more artificial intelligence that is
going to be happening in the future then
there will be human intelligence so that
percentage is raising and that's
something that is again just a concern
to look at and think about so musk
referenced robots moving so fast that
you can't see them without a strobe
light so you know just little even
little tiny nanobots that you can't see
flying around
there's moving super fast or super quick
and you know we're inevitably going to
get there and it's too bad that we're
not having enough of the conversation
about the ethics and about what we're
gonna do geopolitically about it and we
just we need to be focused on doing that
more they used this term like limbic
resonance and I thought that you know I
talked to some neuroscientists and they
thought that that was kind of it was
interesting but it's also it's difficult
to unpack what limbic resonance means
but I thought that in the context that
meant really kind of like this
primordial sort of resonance that when
you use something like Instagram that
you see photos and photos are more
resonant to you and because of your
visual system of perceiving and that is
a very visual is very very primordial
and limbic versus something like like
something prefrontal like organization
of a structuring a company or something
like that it's more difficult for people
to structure a company than it is for
them to scroll through Instagram okay so
again just this this essence about
artificial intelligence and how that he
was working on having people help
regulate it but that it wasn't working
out it would have been nice if maybe Joe
pushed a bit and said you know who did
you talk to what did you talk to them
about what were their responses like
tell us about these prominent figures
around the world that that we're not
taking you seriously let's start calling
people out for not taking it seriously
not taking action about it
so you know must work in neural link is
also very interesting we talked about
brain computer interfaces a bit this
weekend at the brain mind conference at
Stanford and brain computer interfaces
are something that is just insanely
interesting for the future because it's
going to take us away from using ten ten
fingers on a keyboard or two thumbs on a
smartphone and it's going to move us
towards just going through thought so
right now you know we're using voice and
video which is pretty high bandwidth but
it would be even more high bandwidth if
I could just think these thoughts and
they could just go out to the Internet
and so that essence if I could just
think to message just you or if I could
think to just make an event in my
calendar or send an email or whatever it
may be so brain computer interface is
being able to tap into gain any
information to Wikipedia there any of
these sources that you want it's it's
it's crazy how it's gonna change the
bandwidth it's also gonna decrease
miscommunication so for example when I
say the word seven and you hear the word
seven you go oh that means seven but if
I say the word love you might think what
is he talking about is he talking about
loving his mom his dad his girlfriend
his brother or sister or he's talking
about loving a friend what does love
mean to him does that mean a hug it
doesn't mean a kissed as I mean sex does
I mean what does love actually mean does
love mean you give him money you don't
give him money there's all these
different types of things about love
would you die for them would you not so
again it's like we're gonna have a
greater bandwidth in terms of
communication because that my thought
about love you will understand what I
meant without needing to use these words
to try and unpack what it was that can
be very interesting okay something else
that was discussed is about the
biological self dying so if the
biological self dies and you can boot
yourself up on another device like a
robotic exoskeleton that is a huge deal
and if you can figure out how to
translate consciousness into a substrate
that can then be uploaded onto other
things like exoskeleton and live on that
and fly through the sky
I and go and live for hundreds of years
thousands of years at a time that that
is a very promising idea of the future
that you can transcend your biological
body and how would consciousness work we
don't know yet but it's very interesting
thing I would have loved to have more
conversation about that as well and
where that's going how the
technicalities of that actually work so
another aspect to social media is just
that they talked about how people are
posting a lot about how they have a much
better life than they actually do and
that that sort of rebased lining of
expectations is actually really
important for us to analyze and
understand and just see that oh god
we're like not talking about any of our
sadness or our frustration or how we get
through stuff and that kind things we're
rarely ever talking about that we're
totally just posting our absolute best
selves and having a competition of
comparing ourselves and that essence of
comparing ourselves it's the thief of
joy and we really got to understand
that's the thief of Joyce comparing
ourselves in all these different ways
but at the same time comparing ourselves
can be very motivating cuz it can be
like hey Ilan can start a billion dollar
company that changes the world so can I
so I can use it as a tool of inspiration
as well so you know there was
conversation about the simulation
argument being very strong as you guys
know our show is called simulation and
so for example when we have conversation
with our guests and we ask them you know
do you believe we are in a computer
simulation a lot of the times our guests
will say yeah that they think would this
is not base reality and that is becoming
more and more of a popular school of
thought because we do understand that
first of all that this consciousness is
not necessarily strapped to just this
flesh vehicle that this spirit exists in
another place that is not here in this
physical world and also furthermore is
that we are unsure if once we get in
fifty or a hundred years to a point of
indistinguishable virtual realities and
immerse ourselves in them that you just
go and live in a virtual world for 80
years well how is this not that already
so that's why the simulation arguments
very strong
and I'm really happy that they unpacked
that quite a bit it would have been nice
to go even deeper into understanding
what kind of a world we'll live in in a
couple decades when people prefer to
live in virtual realities because the
real world is just boring in comparison
or can we make the real world so awesome
that being in virtual worlds is also
awesome but the real world is still also
great as well so you know there was this
period of time on the show where they
talked about Tesla being the most
enjoyable gift and I think that that's a
really good way to understand Musk's
like design and engineering background
and how much he cares about really
building things of value into the world
and if he and if he says that you know I
want to build the most best gift for
someone and that is a Tesla that that is
why when you sit in a Tesla that it
feels like an amazing experience this
electrical car is just so amazingly
controlled it's amazingly aesthetically
pleasing and it is also able it's
equipped with the best technology and
it's also playful that whole Rainbow
Road thing the whole Easter eggs like
the Siberian Orchestra that plays you
know that you just have to unlock these
things you know no other are automotive
manufacturers are making it enjoyable
like that so in that sense so that is an
amazing thing that gives us a better
perspective into who he is I just I also
think that it would be nice if if if as
they were discussing about all these
nuances of when someone is on you know
you have to grab the wheel every once in
a while in in the autopilot mode and
that you can't just sit there and sleep
for now in autopilot mode so it would be
good to push on that a bit see how far
we are out of our timelines what's gonna
be happening to the parking structures
that are gonna be unused what's gonna be
happening to people's garages what's the
shared economy it's going would have
been nice if Joe pushed Elon a little
bit in the direction of unpacking the
shared economy and seeing what exactly
will happen when Tesla decides to enter
the shared economy and just say that hey
when you're sleeping let your Tesla go
and when you're not using your Tesla
just let it go and conduct ride-sharing
for you and make you money and so it
would have been nice if he pushed that
it would have been also nice if there
was a little bit more push in the
direction of taking Tesla private you
know
that actually mean how would it happen
why are you interested in taking a
private all this type of questions that
people are very interested in that would
have been very good so we're pretty much
done I want to I want to say just a
couple last things on the way out there
was a there was a whole period of time
where they talked on the show about the
about the sort of in terms of the we
were just talking about with the Tesla
that it's being driven that there is no
in the autopilot mode that people are
trying to sue Tesla for causing issues
that caused harm or injury or death and
so during the autopilot mode and so the
general idea is every time someone tries
to take tests a little Court for that
kind of stuff
Tesla wins and it's because judges
understand that a lot of the time people
are just trying to get money out of
Tesla and that it's not actually Tesla's
fault and so they've came up with this
notion that judges and and people
military officers police officers are
generally good people and like the news
is definitely highlighting just the most
atrocious things possible about them and
not necessarily the ones where they're
doing good work so I tend to agree with
them on that the most of them are
ethical most of them are great most
people on the street are generally good
and that's how I typically feel as well
and I'm happy that they brought that up
giving them the benefit of the doubt so
they had this very small segment where
Ilan said mush loop mushrooms are
delicious and I just wished that Jo
would have pushed a bit and said Elon
which psychedelics do you take how often
do you take psychedelics and what do you
feel what do you experience when you
take those psychedelics that would have
been so awesome because I know a lot of
us are really trying to understand
better you know
what types of strategies does does that
unlock for you on that whole process and
what has he done and Joe I believe asked
them about meditation Ilan said
meditation wasn't really as thing that
he likes to be very useful for society
and I thought that was a really
interesting point was that a lot of
people don't think about themselves as I
want to be most useful to society so if
I want to spend my 80 years you know
with my divine
body just working away at building a
better world for the next generations
awesome great for you I'm really happy
and I actually think that way about
myself as well and I want to sacrifice
myself and my life to live them that
leave a better world moving forward so
another another thought about this is
super important is just that if you
think about it Ilana referenced how it
is amazing if his creativity's turned on
that's like millions and millions of
ideas but what if you can't turn it off
what if you can't turn off waking up in
the morning and being Elon Musk or being
Bill Gates there's never a time that you
can turn off your fame and your
billionaire status and your impact if
there's never a time you can turn it off
and just be normal and just normally
walk through the streets like a normal
person what does that do to you so think
about that and what would life be like
if we had a million Tesla's if we had a
million Musk's you know what would that
be like and think about all the
potentials that exist and think about
how if we do turn in if we do turn in as
a society with the singularity that we'd
go into virtual worlds and we go explore
the cosmos in that sense in terms of
simulations and virtual worlds maybe
that is the answer to the Fermi's
paradox that people that civilizations
tend to go inward instead of outward
once they reach a certain technological
progress so this has been some thoughts
on Elon Musk on Joe Rogan what a fun
episode one of the best episodes that
we've ever ever had the pleasure of of
watching two people conduct let's push
for rebirthing the public intellectual
for more of these one-on-one fireside
chats on the internet as well as in live
events let's inspire more people to
build the future and have these nuanced
driven multidisciplinary conversations
we hope you guys had a good time
watching this if you did give us a
comment below with your thoughts
subscribe join the family go and create
content don't just consume this go and
make new videos new posts new businesses
with this type of stuff we'd love for
you to go and build as well huge thanks
to Ron our producer director much love
everyone thanks for tuning in
you soon
[Music]